thank you  we have a dual purpose for today's  assembly so we have now celebrated our  high achievers but we also would like to  celebrate another high achiever  many of the staff at james ruth  have known mr wu as a student  a colleague and a friend  today we celebrate his successful  promotion as head teacher mathematics at  cths my old school terry brooke  and within every success in the future  a true digital native eddie has led the  use of technology in teaching and  learning and is completely responsible  for the development of the dangerous  internet and website  his passions are maths and his and for  his students  is acknowledged and i wish mr woo every  success  i will now pass on to his students to  share their stories of the teacher they  have so much admired  eddie on behalf of the whole school  i wish you a wonderful career and a  prosperous and healthy future for you  and your lovely family best wishes